new dad artem may also want to put some
baby gifts on his shopping list
he and fiance nikki bella who welcomed
son mateo july 31st
just sent this message to fellow dancing
pros lindsey arnold and whitney carson
we're so excited for you both to be new
moms it honestly
is the greatest joy in the whole wide
world there's
no better greater love than this it's
true
yes oh my gosh that it was the sweetest
thing i could almost i was tearing up
i was like tearing up a little bit i was
so sweet
lindsay welcomed her baby girl monday
seven pound 10 ounce
sage jill e.t was with her and whitney
just days earlier at lindsay's home in
utah
this is our first interview together
pregnant it is yeah
you're just so hard because it's her
head
oh that is a full-on skull like just
like
chilling right here whitney is expecting
a baby boy
in january did you plan this no
yes yeah we actually um you know we got
our
husbands we're like hey this is
happening hey guys this is a meeting
that we're having about babies
yes i know it's just it's actually
insane we've done so many things in our
lives together so it's like
naturally why wouldn't we get pregnant
together what are the pregnancy cravings
like what's your late night i have to
have it
babe run to the store um my second
trimester i
would always crave a blue slurpee at the
gas station in a slim gym
lindsay worked out until she hit 35
weeks whitney says she walks every day
to stay active
that's going to be hard though as
dancers i mean your your bodies have
been scrutinized and judged
it is really hard especially when you
get on the scale you're like oh my gosh
i've
never been this heavy but you got to
realize obviously we have
we're growing a human which is amazing
anytime somebody's like you look so big
i take that as a compliment like i'm
like thank you that's good you're like
that's
what's happening i love it and you
know we didn't show up to this e.t
exclusive empty-handed
okay well e.t has a little present for
you oh that was so
nice this is so sweet the best day ever
oh my gosh
[Applause]
let's go i definitely think this is
gonna have to be the coming from home
from the hospital outfit like
without a doubt i love it